Justin Simpson style code if you got it  flaunt it for looks  three days Jessica stone legs on full  display along with a couple of other  things how does the 37 year old mom of  to pull it off shut Rob think these  loops are big now just seen a long time  ago I have been every size opposed to  their favorite look this almost $6,000  full maxi by Gucci saying dear Lord I  love this dress Jeffrey to rock this red  leather miniskirt and crop top but the  lesson here is accessories are  everything those floral Dolce and  Gabbana sunglasses cost a cool $2,600  and that clutch shaped like a mouth is  about 600  [Music]  with this look Jessica teased a new  music is on the way captioning the  record label 1111 coming soon  hashtag stay tuned getaway for that and  ask for the secret to rock in some  serious fashion a lot of squad a lot of  push-ups got to keep these things up you  know you have any diet cream running  around with my kids  that is a diet in itself